hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to in two
minutes so it's been some time since we
last took sneaking Co out for a spin in
Metal Gear Online well that's because
the servers for Metal Gear Online too
got shut down like three years ago but
if you fancy taking your tactical
espionage to the street I mean online
the Phantom Pain's multiplayer branch
Metal Gear Online 3 is out now and as
I'm making this video in advance here's
hoping that it's working otherwise this
will just be embarrassing anyway here's
everything you need to know about MgO so
of course you can design a diamond dog
to your heart's content and you can also
name your new soldier friend but that's
just a nickname for you
it's not what's gonna appear to other
players everyone has a role in MgO so
there's three classes to choose from
scout enforcer and infiltrator each with
their own unique perks and loadouts but
be careful how much gear you suit up
with the weight of all those fancy
weapons and attachments adds up and the
more you carry the slower you'll move as
in previous mgs there are two teams each
with a special team leader character for
Team solid it's venom snake complete
with rocket arm and a laser sight rifle
team liquid players can get their hands
on revolver ocelot who obviously comes
with revolvers I can hit protected
enemies sort of like in that movie with
James McAvoy but better MgO ships with
three modes the first comp control is a
standard zone based mode you capture
comlinks and download Intel while the
opposing team tries to stop you you know
the drill
but then there's bounty hunter which on
the surface is team deathmatch with a
life or ticket limit that's added full
turning and a twist where you build a
bounty on yourself the more enemies you
kill if the other team sends you on a
one-way trip up into the sky then they
take all your tickets like a lucky kid
at the arcade but I was afraid that MgO
seems a little too run-and-gun
try your hand at cloak and dagger which
is similar to team sneak from MgO to a
stealth base mode where everyone has one
life but only one team has the lethal
weapons marking is new to MgO 3 spotting
an enemy's location through your weapon
scope binoculars or discovering them
through interrogation highlights it for
the rest of the team just be aware of
those adorable plushies because
they're so cute that you could forget
what you're doing but what can help hide
you from marking our random sandstorms
and note you can fault in people in
multiplayer sandstorms unlike in the
single-player and yes even though
there's no integrated clan features text
chat or tournament mode that doesn't
mean you can't buddy up you could take a
party of up to eight online with you and
if you salute a buddy in-game you become
linked if you tagged someone it'll
appear for them too if you need help
they'll get notified and you can utilize
the power of wormholes to walk straight
to their location truly detox for life
so there you have it pretty much
everything you need to know about Metal
Gear Online for more on MgO be sure to
check out Mike's preview of the game up
on the site and be sure to keep your
eyes peeled for more on games for calm
thanks for watching guys don't forget
i'm on twitter at Lucy James games and
I'll see you next time